there is so much on Potter that was so  intense and so crazy they're just like  building a tank and they're going to be  filming underwater for six weeks I've  heard that we average like seven seconds  of footage a day or something like of  usable footage those ones on the fourth  film the whole the dragon sequence on  the fourth film  [Music]  one shot on the sick film I think where  I start off underneath the water and I  was on a wire so I was holding myself uh  by a rope under the surface of the water  and then on action I let go and they  pulled me on the wire so I flew out of  the water and there was like a ring of  fire around me so I was just like  bursting out of themselves of the water  through a ring of fire it's phenomenal  that they allowed me to do that myself  and like again I'll never probably be on  a job where they do let me do that kind  of stuff